usually if the person is underneath you
and you don't have your control set up
you're going to have to fill that gap so
you maintain the
line of attack striking
this is generally going to be in close
weapons elbows and knees which
work when you don't yet have power at
least you can get some mass in there
and you'll get some of that power going
okay the elbows and knees versus
punching and things like that and or
legs low kicks and stomps
okay so just a simple one on me
i will get the guy here okay he's
he's here and i'm going to cut through
this to break it
boom then grab the head bone
so that that's what we're going to wear
today
you're going to cut it past it
boom
cut it past it boom either leg
whatever your bow is this won't pop
right here
okay let's try that
okay then watch my hips
to do to do damage they have to drive
forward okay so my mask comes in
because this this was the problem is i
have a guy underneath me
and i don't want him underneath me so
when i
do the strike i need to displace him
he needs to be out away okay so
you know on the head but your knee shot
has to still feed his center put your
hand there
i'll just use your hand okay i have to
be able to
displace him
boom yeah so my hips have to come into
the kit
okay into the kick and i hit my full
bass
okay oh he landed here good
oh this low kick here
so boom boom
okay you have to learn how to strike
the the strikes are not just follow-ups
but they're
looming threats that the person has to
address
and it's the looming threat that sets
them up for the pins
and the throws if there's no looming
threat
let's just take an example he can take
his sweet ass
time bridging the gap do you get it and
then you'll
never get any kind of inertia going so
i'm here and i'm the guy and he has no
strides
he he just knows his kihon waza okay
and i mean
[Music]
um
okay try it again try it again
right do you understand
this i'll never have to commit i can't
do anything
look okay
his looming threats mean i can't
this is dangerous do you see so i have
to try to
try to get past this stuff that makes
his deviations possible
you see so he he deviates up the circle
throw up the circle dude i'll do it
here he goes you see that little
extra half inch when he had to take
another
turn up the spot we'll do it again right
right here
sets it all up sets it up
two you create a fertile training
environment
okay everyone knows how to attack and
you're not doing stupid
so uh
come in with this goofy joe down ski
not even that's not goofy enough go like
this
now i could do that you see i could
do i can do this stuff
go with me
we'll do it
if you know how again stride you know
how to loom
you know how to thread you go no sorry
okay so
i have to learn the body mechanics is
striking
and here's what i'm seeing he's down on
the kneecap
and you're like here
do you see
if my body goes through
do you understand and then i saw the
other
little okay no no no just pull the bag
and i saw this
what's what is that kid
that's what goes to his face
so if you're not throwing it what your
mechanics are there
you can see
you see your hips turn you see the
displacement
of your mouse with his mouth your mass
against his mouth
okay not here
got it okay go
on this one
he is more here
and maybe even trying to get up
right
boom pop this kick is going to be
like a front kick but i'm going to use
my heel so
i'm just going to show it i'm not going
to kick you it goes to the face
boom until it's got boom a stop
on it so that there's he's going that
way
there's a downwardness to it and there
is a
linear thrust to it so pull
both and pull here
kick through
and smooth your transitions out it's not
here
keep the offense going so
okay let's go so this this thumb kick
is not a ball kick i'm going to use my
heel i want to displace him
okay so i did i did the first one
right and his body's there i'm coming in
and
you get it do you guys see that so again
watch your little daisies
he should not be standing there so we do
it
up the thing i'm here
boom knocking again there's his head
through okay try it again
[Music]
i'm here the grip's dead now
you get he absorbed it
he absorbed it you see he comes back up
i'm going to hit and boom
like he comes standing up oh that's
where you're hitting him
okay when you're bringing it first
boom pop rope
[Music]
wow
okay
[Music]
so
the guys guys on you okay
you're supposed to be over here when
he's in front
okay come around get his chin get a chin
strap
so come up get a chin strap
you're going to pass the arms to get rid
of the
uh any gravitant we will pass the arm
and hook the chin
so you empty that kite and nugget
hey guys here grab
it doesn't matter which kite you did
here
yield boom make sure you drop your elbow
around
okay don't do it like this your elbow
goes around the head
so it fulcrums the head so here
and here my elbow is going to go to see
like a crane and i yield
boom
okay try it so remember what we're
trying to do today a lot of you got
jacked up in g was they ended up in
goofy spots and because you're
marginally naive you didn't know really
what to do
okay so we're trying to show you look
there's plenty to do okay
so one of the ones you ended up in was
you jacked up
kaiten and the guys straight you see
so you have to reproduce the mistake
reproduce the mistake
okay now i don't want to bring him into
this double leg
do you see so
this arm is checking and this arm is
checking go
do you see you're not just dead
and i'm not standing out here because
you'll close the gap
so i have my checks my body's here
i secure the chin strap right and that's
when i do the movement
i come back pass boom
[Music]
you can even wait for some of you
some of your new kids were doing right
and just kept pushing
right that was good of you but you're
you're not gonna start going go
and they're like
so you can't you can feed plume you're
here
he's going and i feed that
so this move is close close here
he presses i feed it
okay because i was in front
just like all your stuff
don't check his height to bring him out
of check
this is all very low he pushes
okay
[Music]
crane your wrist
okay so another messed up that was
happening
was you're trying for cutting atomic you
see
but then okay got their elbow straight
just keep the keep the spiral going
keep it locked okay i'm going to use my
shoulder and my forearm i have an arm
bar here
why don't i use it on a spiral geometry
i'm going to bring you around
okay now don't force him down here
force him over see
and then you end up
[Applause]
in your tumor so
trying this you lock keep it going
[Music]
over the other side of the glass here
go to your head mount
boom boom
over
and you can see that that's that is kind
of a opening because you did it all one
handed
first use the other hand you see
the other hand gets in the tongue
so you jacked out because you went one
hand he came over okay fine
boom we're here drop down boom
has to take the opening and you have to
give it
you see then arm bar
boom and just pass it over and drop
okay